a three j'ai reçu la demande précise
d'hélène de personnaliser ses quelques
gadgets à votre attention
donc ce ne sont pas deux poteaux
ce serait fou ici de rendre inopérante
n'importe quel système de sécurité
voilà des photos avec laquelle voyageait
en europe c'est toucher une bombe
lacrymo pourquoi vous lui donnez pas un
look bombe lacrymo sais c'est une bonne
idée je retiens pour plus tard je peux
atteindre 6 enfin s'il voulait en
imprimer une nouvelle
non je devrais rallumer la jet d'encre
j'étais pas très envie chacune de ces
lingettes imprégnées de chloroforme
ça représente un nombre assez perturbant
de lingettes pour les hémorroïdes
patrick ses demandes et l'étendue des
dégâts qui peut y avoir embarqué aucune
idée je ne passeront plus j'ai pas de
problème non plus